If you play games with upscaling enabled
and you want to upgrade to an upper
mid-range graphics card in 2025, should
you purchase the GeForce RTX 570 Ti or
the Radeon RX 9070 XT? That's what I'll
be diving into today, comparing the
GeForce card using DLSS4 to the Radeon
card using FSR4. Along with data from
our previous videos looking into the RTX
5070 and RX970, we'll have a great
picture of how the mid-range market is
stacking up. Right now, there's a price
gap between the 5070 Ti and 9070 XT,
though that gap is not quite as large as
it should be. The 5070Ti is available at
its $750 US MSRP with several base
models in stock at places like Newegg.
The 9070 XT though is still bottoming
out around $650 US, which is $50 above
its MSRP. Does this affect the
comparison in any significant way? Let's
find out after this quick message.
Today's sponsor spot is brought to you
by Wolfbox and their Mega Flow handheld
turbo fans. The Meggaflow 100 features a
150,000 RPM brushless motor that enables
a wind speed of 45 m/s and offers up to
100 minutes of run time. This makes it
ideal for heavy duty tasks like cleaning
your PC while still being capable of
easier jobs with variable speed control.
There's also the Mega Flow 50, a more
budget friendly option that still packs
impressive power with a 110,000 RPM
motor, three-speed settings, and up to
240 minutes of run time. Both models
come with a handful of attachments and
are charged via USB type-C for maximum
convenience. So, for more information,
please check the link in the video
description.
As with previous videos in this series,
the idea here is to provide a different
data set to our day one reviews, which
largely focus on native performance at a
range of resolutions. Native data is
also included today, but the focus is
the main upscaling modes at 1440p,
quality, balanced, and performance. We
want to see what sort of frame rates you
can expect in a realistic gaming
configuration. Does DLSS4 or FSR4 scale
better? And what sort of modes are
required to match the output performance
between each model? As is the case with
any upscaling benchmarks, it's important
to brush up on the visual differences
between DLSS4 and FSR4 because they do
not output an identical image. And so
any performance testing done in this way
is not applesto apples. We have a lot of
in-depth content right here on the
channel that goes into how these
upscalers compare. And they are
important companions for this sort of
performance testing. For testing today,
I'm using the MSI Ventus 3XOC version of
the RTX 5070 Ti and the Sapphire Pulse
version of the RX970 XT in addition to
the MSI Vanguard SOC RTX 570 and ASRock
Steel Legend OC RX970. As these are
different models, some of which have
factory overclocks, all GPUs have been
set to base spec clocks for testing,
which is the standard way we benchmark.
CPU being used here is the Ryzen 7 9800
X3D, 32 gig of DDR5 6000 CL30 memory,
and the very latest game updates,
Windows updates, and drivers have been
used as of earlier this week when the
testing was conducted. So 581.57 for
Nvidia, 25.10.1 for AMD. In both the
GeForce and Radon driver utilities, I've
enabled the global override feature that
upgrades games to the latest versions of
DLSS4 and FSR4, respectively. Let's get
into it. Horizon Zero Dawn Remastered
runs slightly better on the Radeon model
with the 9070 XT coming in 4% faster
using native rendering with this lead
extending to 6% using quality upscaling.
Both of these GPUs offer a nice high
refresh rate experience in this title
when upscaling is enabled and there
isn't much to be gained using settings
below the quality mode. The 5070 Ti
offers performance most similar to the
RX970 in this title. In Ratchet and
Clank Rift Apart, I'm testing using the
very high preset with rate tracing
enabled. And this is relatively easy for
these GPUs to render. The RTX 570Ti is
the faster card in this game as it's 16%
faster than the 9070 XT using native
rendering and 15% faster using quality
upscaling. This means that to get the
same performance out of these models,
the GeForce card can use DLSS quality
mode, whereas the Radeon card has to use
FSR performance, which delivers
noticeably worse visual quality. The
5070 Ti and 9070 XT are neck andneck
using native rendering in The Last of Us
Part One, but the GeForce model manages
to edge ahead by a slim 3% margin when
quality upscaling is enabled. At most, I
saw a 5% advantage to the GeForce card
using the performance mode, but for the
most part, these models offer a similar
experience, around 10% ahead of the
RX970.
Spider-Man 2 is faster on the RTX 5070
Ti, especially when upscaling is
enabled. The GeForce model goes from 11%
faster than the 9070 XT using native
rendering to 19% faster when quality
upscaling is used. And there was a
significant 30% lead in 1% lows. This is
of course with ray tracing enabled, but
it seems that DLSS4 scales a lot better
than FSR4 in this title. And overall,
the game is nicer to play in this
configuration on the RTX 5070 Ti.
Assassin's Creed Shadows is a clear win
for the RX970 XT, offering 15% more
performance using native rendering. And
although this narrows to 10% using
quality upscaling, it's still clearly
faster. I only saw this gap shrink using
performance mode upscaling, which is
probably not a configuration most people
would use at 1440p. And in general, this
is a title where upscaling is less
effective than on average in terms of
the performance boost it provides
compared to native. While performance
was neck andneck between the 5070 Ti and
970 XT in the Last of Us Part One, in
the sequel, I found the Radeon model to
be ahead by 13% using native rendering
and 9% using quality upscaling. The
RX970 was also the faster GPU here,
offering 5% more performance than the
5070 Ti upscaling.
Ghost of Sushima is also faster on the
9070 XT, coming in 8% ahead of the
5070Ti using quality upscaling, which is
similar to the results using native
rendering. This is another title where
the 5070 Ti is a closer match to the RX
9070 as it's just 3% faster than that
model. Stalker 2 is one of the more
difficult games to run across the
selection being tested today, and it's
an interesting case of FSR4 scaling a
little better on Radeon hardware than
DLSS4 on GeForce. This is because using
native rendering, the 5070Ti is 12%
faster than the 9070 XT, but the margin
drops to just a 3% advantage when
quality upscaling is enabled. 1% lows in
our test area also don't push much above
60 FPS regardless of what upscaling
setting is used, which is a problem
related to Unreal Engine 5 traversal
stutter. Marvel Rivals is a close battle
with the 5070 Ti slightly ahead of the
1970 XT. There's a 4% margin using
native rendering and a 5% margin using
quality upscaling. At lower upscaling
settings like performance, the two cards
are basically offering the same
experience. Kingdom Come Deliverance 2
is a win for the RTX 5070Ti, offering
10% more performance than the 9070 XT
using native rendering and 12% more
performance using quality upscaling.
However, this is largely seen when
viewing average performance only. 1%
lows are much closer between these
models, so the Radeon card is more
consistent when upscaling is enabled.
Natively, the 5070 Ti also has a lead in
1% low performance.
Star Wars Outlaws is a title where we
previously saw FSR4 scaling much better
than DLSS4, and this is also true when
adding in the 5070 Ti results. The 5070
Ti goes from 8% faster than the 9070 XT
using native rendering to 8% slower
using quality upscaling. This is because
the 970TXT runs the title 39% faster
with quality upscaling versus native,
but the 5070 Ti only runs 18% faster.
When upscaling is used, the 5070Ti
performs more like an RX970, which you
wouldn't have known if we just looked at
native results. Hunt Showdown is
basically a tie between the 9070 XT and
5070 Ti with the Radeon model ahead by
3% whether we use upscaling or not. At
launch, the GeForce model was
significantly faster in this title, but
driver optimizations have brought the
9070 XT back to where it should be in a
game that is still relatively popular
despite launching over 5 years ago. In
God of War Ragnarok, the 5070 Ti and
9070 XT start out neck andneck at native
rendering, but the 9070 XT is able to
take a 5% lead when quality upscaling is
used. The 5070 Ti is still faster than a
9070 at a given quality mode and up to
13% faster using native rendering, but
typically it sits between these two
Radeon models. Stella Blade is a bad
game for Radeon with the 5070 Ti
delivering its best result yet relative
to the 970 XT. Using native rendering,
it's 29% faster and a similar 27% margin
is seen using quality upscaling. The
GeForce card also has much higher 1% low
performance in the area we test. a 30%
difference using quality upscaling. So
AMD has some work to do to improve
performance in this title. F125 is
another example of the fastest card
changing depending on the metric that we
look at. Natively, the 5070 Ti is 6%
faster than the 970 XT, but this
switches to the 970 XT being 2% faster
when viewing average frame rates using
quality upscaling. Additionally though,
the 5070Ti is 9% faster in terms of 1%
lows. So, the GeForce model is more
consistent, and this is what ultimately
makes it the better choice for this
game. Cyberpunk 2077 using the ultra ray
tracing preset is the heaviest example
of ray tracing out of the games we're
testing today. The 570 Ti is
unsurprisingly 18% faster using this
configuration when rendering natively,
and 13% faster on average using quality
upscaling. But like we saw in F125,
there is a larger difference in 1% lows
with the 5070 Ti having a 24% lead there
using quality upscaling. So, not only is
the 5070Ti faster, it's also the more
consistent GPU. Once you get down to
models like the RX970, frame pacing is
noticeably worse as the card is only
hovering around the 60 fps mark. So, any
dips below that, especially the sorts of
dips we're seeing here, does have more
impact. There's no major difference
between these models when viewing
Hogwarts Legacy performance using the
ultra preset. Natively, the GeForce card
is slightly faster and then using
upscaling, the two are identical, so
it's pretty safe to call this a tie
whether we look at average or 1% low
numbers. Borderlands 4 is another title
that offers similar performance on both
the 5070 Ti and 97TXT using the badass
preset. At most, the 970 XT was 2%
faster using quality upscaling, but this
margin is close enough we call it a tie.
Mafia, the Old Country runs better on
the RX970 XT, coming in 9% faster than
the 5070 Ti native rendering and 13%
faster using quality upscaling. The 5070
Ti performs more like an RX970 in this
title, with the 9070 still slightly
ahead. So, this is quite a good result
for Radeon. On the flip side, Dying
Light the Beast runs best on GeForce
GPUs. Natively, the 5070 Ti is 19%
faster than the 9070 XT, which is one of
the larger margins we've seen in favor
of GeForce. And while this gap shrinks
to 14% using quality upscaling, it's
still the clearly faster GPU. The 9070
XT needs to use at least bounced
upscaling to get in the ballpark of the
5070 Ti quality upscaling. We saw
similar performance between the 5070 Ti
and 9070 XT in the Altters. The GeForce
model was 3% faster natively and the
Radeon model 4% faster using quality
upscaling. This is an example where the
970 XT tended to have better 1% low
performance at a similar average frame
rate and FSR4 tended to scale a little
better than DLSS4.
The last title I'm looking at is
Battlefield 6 in a custom bot match.
Using native rendering at 1440p with the
overkill preset, the 5070 Ti was 5%
faster than the 970 XT. This lead
extended to 9% when using quality
upscaling and 11% using balanced
upscaling. So DLSS is scaling a little
better than FSR here. 1% low performance
is closer between these models, but
typically the GeForce card offers the
faster experience. Now it's time to look
at the 22 game average calculated using
a Geomine. We'll start off by looking at
native rendering where the RTX 570 Ti is
5% faster than the RX 9070 XT. That's
basically the same margin as we saw in
our 55 game benchmark earlier this year,
but a little different to our more
recent 9070 XT retest where we noted the
970 XT is now faster than it was at
launch. In that video, we found the 970
XT was around 3% ahead of the 5070 Ti
across a 16 game average, but this was
largely using rasterized titles, whereas
this game sample today is a mixture of
raster and ray tracing. However, when
using quality upscaling, the margin
between these models is reduced to the
point where the 5070 Ti is just 2%
faster, making it effectively a tie. I
saw similar margins using lower
upscaling modes, 3% faster with bounced,
and 2% faster with performance along
with very similar 1% low performance.
So, across a decent sample of games at
1440p, both raster and ray tracing using
typical upscaling settings, the RTX
5070Ti and RX 9070 XT are very similar.
This data also shows that the 5070 Ti is
15% faster than the RX970 using native
rendering and 9% faster using quality
upscaling. This means that a typical
performance match is the RX970 using
balanced upscaling and the RTX 5070Ti
using quality upscaling. The 5070Ti is
definitely faster and this enables a
better visual output, but they're not
that far apart at 1440p.
On the other hand, the 5070Ti is 27%
faster than the 5070 using native
rendering and 24% faster using quality
upscaling. So there's no DLSS4
configuration the 5070 can use that
matches the performance of the 5070 TI
using DLSS4. In fact, what the 5070 can
do with quality upscaling is very
similar to what the 5070 Ti can do
natively. When we look at the spread of
results between the 5070Ti and 970 XT
using native rendering, we do see more
examples where the 5070 Ti is more than
5% faster. This was the case in nine
games, whereas the 970 XT was more than
5% faster in four games. Typically, the
5070 Ti performs better in rayraced
examples like Cyberpunk 2077, Ratchet
and Clank, and Spider-Man 2. But this
isn't always the case, as games like
Stella Blade, and Dying Like the Beast
do not use ray tracing. When we switch
to looking at quality upscaling, things
even out. There are seven games where
the 570 Ti was more than 5% faster, 10
games that were effectively tied, and
five games where the 5070 Ti was more
than 5% slower. So, these two cards are
both evenly matched on average and when
looking at the spread of results. So, at
the end of the day, would we recommend
gamers purchase the RTX 570 Ti or the RX
9070 XT? Well, if both GPUs were
available at the MSRP, $750 for the 5070
Ti, $600 for the 9070 XT, I think the
Radeon model is the obvious choice.
Performance is basically the same as the
5070 Ti when upscaling is used, and the
970TXT is 20% cheaper. If both cards are
available at the MSRP in your region,
with the Radeon model sitting 20%
cheaper, the 970TXT is the one to get.
Of course, there are nuances to this
discussion because even with very
similar performance on average, the 5070
Ti is still the better overall product.
It has a stronger feature set. DLSS4 is
supported in more titles and typically
has the best image quality. And older
titles have a decent fallback upscaler
in DLSS 3 or 2. While the 970 XT gaming
experience is similar to the 5070 Ti in
titles that support FSR4, it's a very
different experience in titles that
don't, where the GeForce card has a
large image quality advantage. The 970
XT doesn't have a raw performance
advantage that's able to overcome this.
For example, using native rendering,
while the 5070 Ti would use quality
upscaling. Whether or not this
difference in upscaler support matters
to you depends heavily on the sorts of
games you play. If you largely stick to
the latest releases, FSR4 support has
been very good across this year. AMD has
been on top of getting this feature in
brand new titles like Battlefield 6 Day
1, and I'm reasonably confident that
will continue in the future. So, for
those sorts of gamers, what we've been
talking about throughout this video will
apply most of the time. But if you play
a mixture of games, including favorites
from past years, broader DLSS support
may be more appealing. With all of that
said, I think the price and cost per
frame difference between the 1970 XT and
570HI at MSRP mitigates this feature gap
and makes the Radeon model the more
attractive option. Even in heavier ray
tracing examples like Cyberpunk 2077
with ultra ray tracing. Yes, the 5070 Ti
is 13% faster on average with 24% better
1% lows, but it's also 25% more
expensive. At this point, the rate
tracing performance gap is only going to
matter the most if you're interested in
extreme examples like path tracing,
where previously we've shown the 5070 Ti
to be somewhat usable and much faster
than the 9070 XT. Is a better experience
in a handful of path trace games worth
spending 25% more when performance is
similar outside of those games? Even as
someone that mostly plays single player
titles, I'd say no. Right now though,
the 9070 XT is $650 US while the 5070 Ti
is $750, reducing the margin to just
$100, which makes the 9070 XT 13%
cheaper instead of the 20% cheaper that
it should be. That certainly makes the
970 XT less attractive. But given the
models offer similar performance using
upscaling at 1440p, I don't think opting
for the 9070 XT is an outrageous
decision. It's okay value, but not the
good value it would be if it was $600.
The real winner here appears to be the
RX970,
even in a comparison to the 5070 Ti, as
it's available at its $550 MSRP. This
makes the 5070 Ti 36% more expensive for
just 9% more performance when upscaling
is used at 1440p. On a cost per frame
basis, this makes the 9070 20% cheaper
per frame, which is a very decent
position. And this is the same
difference we should see between the
9070 XT and 5070 Ti at their respective
MSRPs.
There are some occasional examples where
the 5070Ti is much faster than the 9070,
but most of the time the 9070 is within
the same ballpark and you can achieve
similar results through small setting
tweaks. That seems reasonable given the
$200 price difference and crucially both
cards have the same amount of VRAM. In
Australia, things are even more
favorable to Radeon. Right now, the RTX
570 Ti is available as low as $1,400.
And the RX970 XT is at $1,100. So, this
is the 20% cost saving we should be
seeing in the US at MSRP. But the RX970
is just $900, making the 5070 Ti 55%
more expensive for just 9% more
performance. So, the 9070 XT is good
compared to the 5070 Ti, but the RX970
is even better. There's not much more to
say here, so that's it for this video
really. If you appreciate these sorts of
comparisons and performance reviews,
even months after these cards have
launched, then consider subscribing to
the channel and supporting us on
Patreon. Links to that is in the
description below. If you sign up, you
get access to some pretty cool benefits
like our Discord community, monthly live
streams, BTS content, and plenty of
other good stuff. So, thanks for
watching, and I'll catch you in the next
one.